well friday night we all got hit by the
terrible news that ruth bader ginsburg
has passed away at the age of 87
or fifth bout of cancer and i was
talking to someone
and they said i think at least what i
felt it's like you kind of felt like she
was going to
hang on until after this election and it
was clear that she was fighting to hang
on
and she's a very strong person but
her strength ran out you know we're all
human
and she passed away friday night
uh and the question is uh what does this
mean
i mean the first thing uh is you you
honor the passing of an icon someone
who's a trailblazer
uh uh for really
um women certainly in the legal field
but she i think she was bigger than
than that where she stood up for
uh an evolving sense of what human
rights were over her career
really transcended generations you know
i mean what a full life
i think someone said it's like you know
you can't imagine living
a more impactful more important life
leading
a more important career than she did so
on one hand
you just look up and and say wow like
so grateful that she was among us and
did what she
has done um and
that lasted unfortunately for apparently
about uh 30 seconds
before then people started turning
towards what this means
in terms of the supreme court uh this
election
whether trump is going to nominate
someone which i think he announced he is
going
to and then whether the senate would
move forward to confirm
uh new justice despite the fact that the
election
is at this point 44 days away
and the average supreme court
confirmation process takes 2.2 months
and that's in a normal circumstance so
so to me it's really
awful that after sandbagging merrick
garland
uh in 2016 where they say hey
look it's only a year until the election
like let's not
deal with this until after the election
uh
and then now when you're in the reverse
situation but instead of having a year
you have six weeks and you're like no no
this time we're gonna
we're just gonna cram this through
because it's uh you know
a different situation um like that
strikes i think
any reasonable person is utterly
ridiculous uh
and awful and [ __ ] like you know
it's just a clear
uh double standard where you take one
approach if it's a justice that
represents
a viewpoint you don't like and then when
the shoe's on the other foot then then
you take a totally different approach
so here's a couple thoughts um one like
we
it's heartbreaking like she was a legend
um even
president trump was asked like if we got
a they got a very real
candid reaction of him because he found
out the news friday night from a
reporter
after his rally um which
quick comment his team should have told
him between
the walk from the rally to his press
that's what we would do be like hey by
the way if so-and-so died or this broke
they have news whatever it is anyway
he did say wow like i have nothing to
say except she's an amazing woman like
she lives an amazing life um this is
very sad
something like that um then it is
heartbreaking the reality is
though what you just said is that this
is going to be extremely politicized and
we're not going to wait it's just going
to it's already started
um so i thought it'd be we wanted to hop
on the pod
and break this down um
because this is your september surprise
this will be the focal point election
and
tim alberta who's one of our buddies
from the campaign um
just wrote a piece in politico talking
about what trump
and mcconnell would or could do but one
of the things that's fascinating andrew
and this is why it matters
is that the supreme court
is and i quote the most and quote the
most important factor
in voting for president or when they go
to vote
for 21 of the electorate 21
of all voters this is the mo this is the
thing they care about
um so thoughts on how this
affects republicans affects democrats
like it's gonna affect this is
the most important thing for almost
everybody um when it comes to voting
and you now have this hanging of the
balance before one of the more important
elections we've ever had
well one legitimate reason to be
concerned about having an even number of
justices right now and
this is before uh you know we get to
what you just described
is that back in 2000 the supreme court
essentially helped decide the election
between
uh al gore and good point and and
george w bush uh you know they decided
5-4
along unfortunately party lines uh about
what to do with the florida recount
uh and and so you have a very real
impact on potentially the resolution of
the election
which to me is another reason why it's
it's terrible for
us to try and cram a new justice in and
then have that justice literally maybe
turn around and decide an election
uh days later i mean like i don't think
that strikes anyone as a good idea
but to your point there are millions of
americans
who have been focused on the supreme
court and other
courts around the country and
republicans have done a superior job
of motivating their base around uh
judicial appointments
uh they they're very very
consistent on that and they they care
more about
non-supreme court judicial appointments
i believe
uh than the other side uh
and they're smart because those
judges end up deciding a lot of things
uh that never even get to the supreme
court i mean it's not like the supreme
court hears everything you know that you
have to go through
several levels uh to get there and that
is how
trump won over the evangelical right
is that hey you don't have to love trump
but he's going to stand for conservative
values
on you know in on our supreme court
here's a list of justices i'm going to
nominate you drop that in may of 2016
before the election so that's sorry to
interrupt
that a big no no no not all you're right
they're very smart and deliberate about
they focused on this yes they knew it
they knew the numbers
and evangelical voters listen and they
say look i can
hold my nose and vote for this man
because he's going to stand up for
the things i care about if they're
against it or whatever whatever they
believe in yeah well
i mean that that's that's i think the
most common issue
for folks who are focused on uh these
appointments
is the is pro-life uh versus
pro-choice the big one yeah so
the question now if you look at the
actual ins and outs of nominating and
confirming
uh a supreme court justice you need
several republican senators
to say look i'm not going to do this uh
given the timeline given the
circumstances
um you need approximately three to come
out and say that
that they're not down for this hurry up
confirmation process uh and there
there's a real possibility that those
three republican senators exist
so if you and i i believe
at least a couple of them have already
signaled that they are not going to go
along with a
confirmation process and some of them
are up for reelection right now
in right really tough races uh susan
collins and maine
um is one of them so
hope is not lost in the sense that uh
there's a real chance
that enough senators look up and say
look it's
it's really really uh not
appropriate for us to cram uh supreme
court justice uh in this time frame
six weeks before an election uh you know
after we essentially waited a year uh in
2016
saying that the people should decide i
think if we have a consistent message
right now it should be
let the people decide but you know and
and to your point about how this is
going to affect
the election it's going to energize
voters
on both sides uh there are many people
who are going to look up and say
wow we need to get trump reelected
because he can appoint a replacement to
ruth bader ginsburg
and there are many voters around the
country who say we really need to
get joe and kamala elected because
they're gonna appoint a replacement
uh to ruth bader ginsburg and that to me
is appropriate
like that is a much much better process
for us to determine
who replaces rbg than
doing this completely rushed
and inconsistent with past practice
confirmation process that some people
are looking to um
to shepherd through in record time i
mean the whole thing
just leave a terrible terrible sense uh
in many many americans minds as to
what this process became
and especially if it turns out that this
new justice ends up having an impact on
the outcome of the election because
there is a real chance that there are
legal challenges associated with this
election
i think this probably is a net positive
for republican turnout more than
democrat turnout in the sense that i
feel like democrats have a million
reasons
to want to vote against the donald or
feel their principles violated in
certain ways
but republicans may have been on the
fence but i don't love this trump guy i
think
i'm just going to stay home are now like
well i now know i'm get
my vote if we win guarantees a
conservative justice on the
on the court um that is more powerful
now let me ask you this um or could be
more powerful let me ask you this though
um this is what tim alberta's point
which is fafsa he's like if
so on one hand trump could say hey i
want to nominate a supreme court justice
before the election here it is i'm gonna
get done um
because who knows or they could wait
they could say like
elect me and i will do this um and even
if he loses
they still might be able to pass this
thing and approve it between the end of
you know november 3rd remember that we
count the votes and
when mike pence swears in uh
the next you know the next senate right
the next congress i think that's the
vice president's job
do you and that's his point he's like
mitch mcconnell has options here and he
might actually choose to wait
um because he can still get what he
wants but it affects the election a
different way
what are your thoughts on how to play
that or if they which way they'd lean
either
i don't know it's interesting question
well the excitement for
republicans could be
elevated either way like if you don't
if you don't get the justice say look
you got to vote for trump so we can get
this justice
that's very very uh powerful motivation
if they get the justice through
i would argue that you know you would
also motivate the same group of voters
because they would see that
that voting for trump gets results in a
particular way
yeah so uh but i agree that there there
is a
tactical issue uh you know it could be
exciting to republican voters
who are motivated around this uh to say
uh you gotta get out there if you want
this justice um
i i would also suggest though that to me
let's say trump loses and that
outcome is determined in mid-november
and then
for the senate then to turn around and
say hey the american people chose joe
but now we're
still going to go ahead and cram in this
appointment um
i think that they would have a very very
hard time convincing both the american
people
and even the republican senators
that that was appropriate in the least
i think there would be a half a dozen
republican senators uh who would stand
up and say
look uh you know we just lost an
election
uh you know like we're literally in a
lame duck session
in the last month the waning days of of
of of this senate like some of us are
leaving like
like i don't think um i don't think that
process
uh would would uh stand up personally
i mean like i've been wrong before about
because you know people
people aren't very principled in some of
these situations but i think that would
be
in some ways the uh most distasteful
approach
so here's what i'd say i want to know if
you agree with this like this is
all we can kind of say right now because
you never know how these things play out
um but here's what i'd say to look out
for i don't want your thoughts about you
think i'm right i say one
look out for the republicans to use this
i will say extremely well
to help trump win in 2020. um because i
think mitch mcconnell
while he's a scumbag and the definition
of a hypocrite
he's a genius he is a political genius
if you will like he's a mastermind
at winning elections he should not win
and getting things passed it should not
be passed and doing things the american
people do not
like or even um have any sort of
tendency to approve
on a majority basis but i'd say
political side from the republicans
gonna use well i think
i'd be interested to see how this
engages the um the women's vote in 2020
that's the second piece of this um
because i do think that's what rbg stood
for and that that puts this issue front
and center on the ballot to me
um and then third i'm really
interested in how the democrats can
respond to this without
um frankly looking kind of lame or soft
where it's like
no don't do it wait for us or you know
like
like
without looking reactive or passive in a
certain way um but those are my three i
don't know anything to watch out for
what you think
yeah the the the message should be let
the people decide
uh we have an election that's a good
message in in six weeks
uh one reaction i did see uh
that people were taking right now is to
donate to mitch mcconnell's opponent amy
mcgrath
uh and and i would suggest that there
are a couple of better things you could
do
than that though that that's a very
natural emotional reaction
um but amy mcgrath's not hurting for
money
um right now she's not going to lose
because
enough money yes extra dollars are not
going to make
there are nine senate races open that
are closer right now that could use the
money sorry
you know exactly that's exactly right
like like if you're
thinking i'm gonna donate um to mitch
mcconnell's opponent
pick one of the other races uh and
donate to them instead
uh like lindsey graham's opponent jamie
harrison's actually neck and neck with
him in south carolina that's
a political earthquake in the making so
you don't you can donate um
there like there are a bunch of other
races that make more sense
uh and the the second thing is
to try and put pressure on some of these
moderate republicans who are going to be
uh trying to decide whether or not to go
along with this
hurry up confirmation process so mitt
romney's one
uh lisa murkowski is another susan
collins is another uh and there are a
couple of others
that i believe are swayable um
and that could be for political purposes
if they're up for re-election um
or it could be uh no
uh just an emotional appeal as like
you're their constitution
constituent let's say you're their
constituent
and uh you voted for them and didn't
vote for them say look you know you're
like you're my senator
uh like i feel strongly that you should
just let the
people decide let the election go like
uh
you know working on the winnable senate
races and then working
on the moderate republicans who are
going to decide this thing um
or their opponents if that's the way you
decide to go you know like
then uh that to me would be
like a couple of very concrete things
that you could do
another thing would be just to do more
of whatever you're doing now
so phone bank call people
text bank volunteer make sure and vote
get your friends to register to vote
particularly in swing states
around the country um so those are some
of the things that that i think we
should be doing the senate
looks very very uh winnable
for dems this cycle where
they could get a slight majority if they
win some of these races
so the senate races that are close
and closer to mcgrath's are in maine
north carolina south carolina
georgia arizona michigan colorado texas
even alaska so those are a number of
states
um give me more info yank speaks
listeners um
so i agree um we learn this a lot when
we're running is that if you actually
call your congressman
or senator they don't get a lot of calls
like this so
if you're in one of these states and got
five friends to call that actually has a
way bigger impact than you'd think
um because people are like oh you don't
listen to people the people don't
actually talk to them very often
um so that actually works let me ask you
this
i think it's a good way to close is this
feels dark
to me this is a sad day this is a sad
moment
um i i think ignoring your political
ideology
i think a balanced court is better than
an overweight republican one
particularly when i think the
the like the popular vote voted for
clinton
last time but like i think the majority
of the country is leaning more left at
least in terms of sheer numbers
um so this feels dark and heavy
um and there's a lot of people out there
who are looking for a sign of hope
what do you what's the positive spin on
this what to you gives you hope as we
come down the pipe
post rbg's legacy
first it really is reflecting on what a
tremendous uh
figure and leader she was just
feeling like a sense of history i mean
uh
evelyn was incredibly sad uh to hear of
her passing just
americans around the country uh are are
devastated and just reflecting on what
she's
she means to so many of us i i was
actually thinking to myself wow her
passing
i was trying to think of other people
that would have had a similar impact
on on millions of people around the
country and it's a very very short list
i mean she's really
one of the sort of the mount rushmore of
of uh living american figures and you
know until this week
um uh that and one of
so there i think there are a few reasons
why we're sad right now
they're and they're all important number
one is a human being that we all
that we all admired and treasured is is
gone
uh number two is the tough truth that
while trump has con nominated and
confirmed to supreme court justices
they were replacing conservative
justices uh so we we still as you're
saying zach have like a moderately
balanced court i mean unfortunately a
lot of rulings have been going 5'4
along party lines um with roberts as
sort of the swing but you still have
this sense of balance
rbg is a very progressive
vote and if you replace the progressive
vote with a very
uh conservative justice and some of the
folks that they have
on the short list uh to be the
next supreme court justice are very
conservative
uh then that's a a major major
shift for the court where you have then
six three or five four
conservative majorities consistently
down the board which is why we're
all hurting uh on the side and then the
the third thing
is this forbidding sense that
the senate may abandon principle and uh
and and because of the abandonment of
principle there's a sense that our
institutions are
eroding even further in many ways i feel
like this election is about the
integrity of american institutions and
our trust in them and that that trust
has been slipping for years and decades
for a variety of reasons
uh and now the the supreme court which
many of us have already questioned
um whether it's truly an apolitical
entity over the last number of
months and years but like now is in
danger of becoming
uh you know even more uh
of a political football it feels like
you know what i mean like you
and and so like i mean heck i remember
reading supreme court rulings and like
spending hours like pouring over the
reasoning and whatnot
and then now it seems like that stuff's
not actually how these things go down
it's just like well
you know like we were there we pointed
this person
i felt like i feel like people were like
they had their party line you know they
were going and then someone wrote some
sort of dissertation or response
whatever it's called explaining it in
the blanks yeah like backing into it uh
you know
and each supreme court justice has four
brilliant clerks uh who are like some of
the best law school grads in the country
that frankly you you could get like a a
pretty good explanation for
that get it right debate you debated you
know you take the other side yeah for
sure
and there are logical reasons for a
whole bunch
i mean like whether you agree with them
or not you can find fact to support your
opinion
all the time um sorry keep going i mean
i mean
it's like a sinking feeling the sinking
feeling you have because you know like
you like to believe that legal reasoning
transcends uh
like political beliefs um so so these
are the reasons why we're all sad zach
and like they're all very legitimate
important reasons
uh like the the the thing i would say
that
um you can take away from this um
that you could frame as a positive is
that
this will make it indisputably
crystal clear to everyone on both sides
on any side how important this election
is like
all of a sudden you know you you look up
and say wait a minute
there are a lot of fundamental
legal rights that you may take for
granted now that may actually be
changed or called into question uh in
the days to come
uh and so if
uh if there were folks who were who were
on the fence about
getting out there and voting um on
either side
and there is this instinct that you you
suggested before that tim suggests that
it's like that this is going to energize
one side more than the other
um but to me the positive from this
is to just show how important this
election is going to be and that
we all need to do everything we can uh
to get people out to vote
to uh to fight for the candidates that
we believe in
because there's a lot at stake like a
lot of things that
we have grown to just believe as true
about american life
um may be called into question
uh if this election goes in a particular
direction
i think what gives me hope is this yes
it puts importance on the election
and your best case scenario right now to
me is we
we turn out as a country cooler heads
prevail
in november and it's such a stomping
that
your congressmen your senators are on
the way out they're
ideally embarrassed from a clean sweep
and that there's no way in their right
mind without massive
revolt um that they would try to push
this across the finish line after the
american people speak on november third
that to me is
is a realistic outcome in our best case
i think
no i think there's a chance you see
record turnout um in part because i
think there are some folks who are going
to be voting at higher levels because of
mainland voting right you know
actually it's easy and people are you
know they're getting i mean i love like
people to me the envy every single nba
player right now is wearing like vote
and running ads like to me that's it
that that's never happened for my
lifetime
i don't think it has a zero impact um
and if it gets five thousand
ten thousand fifty thousand hundred
thousand people in tummy swing states to
vote
i got a whole new election and i will
say fyi
people following in the democratic
primary this year
2020 record turnouts record turnouts
for biden for biden um the same
primaries we were in in iowa new
hampshire
record turnouts so that gives me hope
you know um yeah let's let's yeah let's
get out there and fight for it and vote
i mean that that's really the
big message you can take from this uh
and and continue to be inspired by
ruth bader ginsburg because you can
imagine the arc of her life and her
career and
the impact she's had i mean like you
know uh if
any of us can accomplish anything even
like you know five ten percent of that i
mean like you know
we'd consider ourselves very very very
fortunate we'd be successful
yeah so thank you guys for tuning in
this is our first kind of
rapid response but this is the fitting
one right no better reason than
than the passing of a goat if you the
goat um
yeah it's you know passing a historic
figure
uh let's make her proud you know the the
thing i'd say is like for people who are
sad right now just take that sadness and
translate it into action because
that's what she would want for us